[Music]
how important is business strategy to
healthcare organizations the success of
your organization now and in the future
depends on key business principles like
understanding the industry you're in and
the forces that make it easy or
difficult to create and capture value in
this course we'll consider real world
case studies and you'll think through
the strategic decisions that leaders had
to make you'll face challenging
questions and gain practice in thinking
through options and making trade-offs
you can then apply this approach to
challenges facing your own healthcare
organizations we just need to know what
makes the organizations and the
healthcare sector work more efficiently
and it isn't just competition we should
look at how management practice works we
should look at regulation being aware of
what's happening in the market
and then really thinking about how our
clinic or our skill set could play in
that market becomes
critically important any entity that
contemplates a merger should be
evaluating closely what a concrete
objective
measurable benefits you believe you can
get out of that merger this course will
help you align the principles of
business strategy with the unique
challenges of healthcare organizations
in the u.s enabling you to identify how
to create and capture value in these
markets while the course focuses on u.s
healthcare and institutions the business
strategies and principles can be applied
more broadly to a range of settings
combine the best business strategies
with the fundamentals of the healthcare
sector
[Music]